in a world where a bunch of rich people
dress up in fancy clothes to give each
other trophies these eight films will
compete for Hollywood's highest honor
being the answer to the question what
did win the Oscar last year the honest
nominees for Best Picture are from Adam
McKay the guy who brought you Talladega
Nights stepbrothers and anchorman 2
comes a sobering look at the financial
crisis of 2008
wait what so Wall Street crashes the
economy for profit it got away with it I
would be so outraged right now if I
understood what the hell was going on
whenever you hear subprime sorry Margot
Robbie I appreciate that you're in a
bathtub and all but I still get it no
money mo problems gear up for the most
badass nominee for best pictures since
ever
as George Miller's brutal world blurs
the line between apocalyptic madness and
Australian people being Australian he's
a crazy Smeg who eats schlanger
hey it's nominated for Best Picture not
Best Screenplay all right
furiosa Road featuring Mad Max deep in
the woods of North Dakota revenge is a
dish best served cold like so cold you
have to sleep inside a horse but we
really want to do an actual honest
trailer for this movie and we don't have
the footage yet so we're saving our best
jokes for later
long story short Leo grunts his way to
an oscar frozen journey back to a time
when news was printed on paper and
delivered to your home for a movie that
really nails the look and feel of Boston
that Bostonians probably wish was set
literally anywhere else 90 priests is
that possible but don't worry they're
everywhere
in this well-acted super-depressing
episode of Dateline NBC that made
audiences everywhere say great I
probably live next to a pedophile priest
- Newsies might want to avoid these
houses from Steven Spielberg and Tom
Hanks comes a competently made by the
numbers drama about the cold war that
your dad definitely saw and you'll
probably catch on a plane some time but
when you're Steven Spielberg and Tom
Hanks even your average movies get
nominated for Best Picture by default
hey
they both done better than this but come
on they've earned it not nearly enough
spies from the director of your favorite
sci-fi movies and also prometheus comes
the film that's basically castaway in
space which was technically already
gravity which makes this gravity on Mars
so hold on to your sides for what the
Golden Globes declared the best comedy
of the year I die I need you to check-in
parents I know that sucks talking to a
couple about their dead son get it it's
funny because he thinks he's never gonna
see his family again survivor Mars in
the city of Brooklyn
I assume comes the story of an immigrant
lady who falls in love with her
I'll be honest I haven't seen Brooklyn
in either of you
I hear it's great though you can only
see so many movies gear up for one of
the best movies of the year which
unfortunately almost shares a title with
the worst movie of all time you're
tearing me apart Lisa that features
amazing action and direction but is so
depressing we're just gonna run all the
times they say room in the movie room
fro double starring the larious Matt
Damon Leonardo Det Oscar doe Dom Hana
Gleason Pelt's a lady driver okay there
tell me to wrap it up okay uh bar fader
even-tempered max Oh
oh man so many names okay okay um
sabertooth
Lars Ulrich okay Turner and Russkies a
pedophile priests ah rapist
um the evil banks sirsir re-grease Ronin
um I don't have time for that one and uh
yeah and no black people the Oscars the
big show was great but let's be honest
it wasn't the best movie about five guys
trying to stick it to the man this year
I got some misete be sure to subscribe
for more honest trailers hey screen
junkies want to watch the Oscars with us
then tune in to our live Oscar watch
party right here on YouTube featuring
your favorite screen junkies
personalities the stream starts this
Sunday at 5 p.m. Pacific time as we give
our honest take on this year's ceremony
and since everyone in Hollywood is
giving stuff away we're giving you a
chance to win a free one-year
subscription to screen junkies plus
check the link in the description below
for your chance to take home screen
junkies gold superhero landing she's
gonna do a superhero landing I love
apples and bananas weenus
cable guy I pooped my pants and told no
one a journey of a thousand miles begins
with a singe step